زاويتنا في مسائل العربيه هذه المره
الادعايه الانتخابيه هل تعيد المحاكمه
الرئيس السابق ترامب الى الرئاسه معنا عبر
سكارم واشنطن الكاتب الصحفي اهلا
بالفعل هذه المحاكمه قد تحدث مفاجاه وتعيد
ترامب الى الرئاسه
اعتقد ان هذه المحاكمه سوف تحمل في طياتها
مفاجاه قد لا تذكر بالضروره عوده الى
البيت الابيض فعدد كبير من الديمقراطين
والجمهوريين الذين
ينظرون الى مساله هذه التي نعيشها وقد
يعتقدون بانها سوف تعزز من قاعدته وتعزز
من ترشيحه هو وقد تحقق نصرا كبيرا
اذا ما كان هذا الامر واضحا لكن لدي
الاسباب لتدفعني للاعتقاد بصحه الامر
هل ستكون هذه المحاكمه هي القبله التي
ستعيد ترامب للحياه
[موسيقى]
لا اعلم اذا ما كانت سوف تعيده الى الحياه
لكنه قد تضعه في
وسط الاحداث حيث سوف يكون تحت بقعه الضوء
من خلال
الحمله الجمهوريه
للانتخابات
وفي ذات الوقت سوف تقود كافه الانجازات
والانشطه التي حققتها اداره بايدن
والتركيز سوف يكون على الدوله وهذا هو
دونالد ترامب وانا لست متاكدا اذا ما كان
هذا امر جيد ام سيء توقعاتكم بشان التهم
الموجهه لدونالد ترامب الى اي مدى بالفعل
قد توجه له توهم قد ترقيل تهم جنائيه ام
ان هذا مستبعد
انا لست بمحامل هنا
ولائحتي الاتهامات لا تزال قيده سريه
وكانت كذلك حتى اخر المعلومه قراناها ولا
نعلم ما هي طبيعه التهم لكن هناك البعض
منها الذي بات معروفا وبعضها يعود الى
الاتهامات التي وجهت الى ترامب فيما يتعلق
بقيام مايكل محامي ترامب بدفع اموال لشراء
صمت
احدى
الممثله اباحيه من اجل عدم تقديم اي
ادعاءات بانها قامت باجراء علاقه غير
مشروعه مع الرئيس السابق ترامب
وهناك ايضا تزوير لبعض السجلات التجاريه
لست متاكدا اذا ما كانت هذه واحده من
القضايا الاخرى التي سوف تكون محطه النظر
لكن اذا ما كانت هذه اللائحه الاتهامات قد
تغطي بعض الجرائم فهي قد ترتفع قد تنخفض
من جريمه الى جنحه فكل محامي تحدثت اليه
قال ان هذه القضيه ضعيفه للغايه وليست
لديها المقومات الكافيه
وهذا يعزى الى ان الانشطه الاساسيه في هذه
القضيه لا يمكن الاخذ بها قانونا
في العاده يتجنب الساسه في اي بلد في
العالم يتجنبون الفضائح خصوصا المرتبطه
بالفضائح الجنسيه اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
لائحه اتهامات مرتبطه بالرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب من بينها فضيحه وفضاء
جنسيه ودفع اموال لممثله الافلام الاباحيه
كيف نفسر هذا الدعم من قبل مناصري الرئيس
الامريكي الذي مازال مستمرا حتى هذه
اللحظه رغم كل هذه التهم الموجهه نتحدث عن
اكثر من ثلاثين له
اعتقد بانه علينا ان ناخذ في وجه الاعتبار
ان الحزب الجمهوري ليس
ذلك الحزب
المتدين او المتعصب دينيا
بالمقارنه مع
اليسار الذي قد يحمل تلك الصفه لذا
بالنسبه لاناس كثر فهم هذا يرون بانه هذا
الامر ليس بذات اهلاويه اذا ما قام بغش
زوجته فانهم يرون ان هذا ليس من شانه وليس
من عملي ولا يهمني الامر لذا اناس كثروا
يصنفون تحت هذا النموذج وهناك اناس اخرون
ممن يعتقدون
ان اترمت قد قام بخداع زوجته وخيانتها وقد
لا يروق لهم الامر لكن هناك مساله اكثر
واهميه في قد تتعلق بالتضخم واسعار الطاقه
وامني
المساكن وقدره الحصول عليها اما ويرون انه
في ظل بايدن فانه رئيس ضعيف قد ارتفعت ضخم
الى مستويات وشل قدره المواطن الامريكي
على شراء
الوقود لسياراتهم وقد دهور الوضع العالمي
اذا ما كان هناك خيار بين الرجللين فان
هناك واذا ما نظرتم الى قام به ترامب قبل
فكانت هناك حاله من الازدهار والسلام
وكان يسعى لجعل امريكا عظيمه مجددا وهناك
اناس كثر ممن يؤكدون هذا الامر وهناك فريق
اخر ممن لا يقفون في معسكر ترامب وقد يرون
عكس ذلك لكنهم يعترفون ضمنا بان هذه
الجهود لاتهامه في مدينه نيويورك قد تكون
ضعيفه وخاليه من المقومات القانونيه
ومسيسه وهذا امر لسنا بوضع لنؤكد مدى صحته
من عدم حتى نرى لائحه الاتهامات ويحق
لاترمت ان يدفع ببراءته الى حين ثبوت عكس
ذلك واثناء المحاكمه ولست متاكدا اذا ما
سوف على محاكمه عادله في منهات لكنه يستحق
ذلك ولو كنت في مكانك فكنت سوف اطلب بنقل
المحاكمه الى جزء اخر من ولايه نيويورك
فهذا امر روتيني في السلطات القضائيه
والقانونيه الامريكيه للحصول على محاكمه
القانونيه في مكان مختلف عن ذلك المكان
الذي قدمت فيه الى احد الاتهامات وتغيير
مكان المحاكمه ونقلها الى مكان يظن المدعي
عليه بانه سوف يحصل على محاكمه عادله هذه
هي هذا هو حجر الزاويه في النظام القضائي
الامريكي والناس يتناسلون وهذه الحقيقه
فمثل الناس ولكن انتهى الوقت شكرا
جزيلا في خلال هذه الساعه كل ما هو جديد
وياتينا من نيويورك اليوم في هذا اليوم
التاريخي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في الكاتب صحفي واشنطن شكرا لك